Samir Ibrahim: Who’s ready for a story?
Audience: Yes.
SA: Alright.
Once upon a time, in a land
very very close to us,
there was a planet.
And that planet was on fire.
But it didn’t start that way.
Global atmospheric
carbon dioxide concentrations
in parts per million
for the past 800,000 years
didn’t exceed 300 parts per million.
And that peak happened
about 300,000 years ago.
The annual rate of increase
of atmospheric carbon dioxide
as measured in parts per...
oh...
looks like you’ve fallen asleep.
(Laughter)
Climate change is the most urgent issue
facing humanity today.
But telling you a boring story
like I just did
is not going to create the change we need
to secure a livable future.
We need climate activism to be mainstream.
We need the fight against
climate change to be cool.
Let’s try something different.
Ladies and gentlemen, please welcome
MyVerse and Kristen Warren.
(Applause)
[Music]
MyVerse: Dear children.
Hope you listen
This is Mother Earth
From beyond your birth
I been here when the Sun emerged
I fed you from me for no love returned
To see you grow up and be undeserved
In other words
Let me nurture
Don't let them deceive
You self-sufficient
cause you get it from me
That light bill from the sun
paid definitely
Don't let them hustle you your power
cause the energy free
I gave mountains to guide you
And rivers to ride through
Trees to help you breathe
but don't seem to be mindful
that other creatures need ya
cause they live here beside you
A Mother's Nature make sure
that you fit for survival
Like finish your greens
Eat less than your eyes do
Take the trash out
be disciplined and recycle
Seasons getting heated scolding
y'all will be frightful
You gon’ learn to clean ya room
when you live under my roof
Kristen Warren:
Blessed creatures fall and die
Wildfires in their eyes
Stop waiting for a sign
Please ease your Mother's mind
In Eden we could be
Take care of you and me
While waters swell and rise
Please ease your Mother's mind
MV: Dear Mother Earth,
Where do we begin?
To change all this mess left for us to fix
We made aesthetics be the reason
that this threat exists
They want our votes
to address it til' elections end
Cause politicians and these businesses
are best of friends
Some cut cost to up profits
but at what expense?
Accountability is knowing
this affects our kids
It made me realize that my part
in this is just as big
Too much convenience kept
polluting up my human nature
Minor changes can be mega
for future's favor
Reduce waste, reuse plates
I mean actually try
With better habits they can't gas us
if we travel on bike
To my family goin' green
tryin' to lead the effort
Of less carbon footprints
Be the cleanest steppers
Ain't no favorites climate change
it could reach whoever
Cause it don’t matter what class,
we still breathe together
KW: Blessed creatures fall and die
Wildfires in their eyes
Stop waiting for a sign
Please ease your Mother's mind.
In Eden we could be
Take care of you and me
While waters swell and rise
Please ease your Mother's mind
MV: Same mother, same truth
Please read this letter
Same sky, same water
We drink together
Same soil, same root
We eat together
It don't matter what class
We still breathe together
KW: Please ease your Mother’s mind
(Cheers and applause)
Samir Ibrahim: How do you
create a movement?
How do you raise the masses?
How do you get people behind
an idea to inspire action?
You make it mainstream.
In 1993,
Snoop Dogg released his song
"Gin and Juice," produced by Dr. Dre.
Some people know it here.
It peaked at number eight
on Billboard's Hot 100 chart
in the United States,
and it was nominated
for a 1994 Grammy Award
for Best Rap Solo Performance.
The lyrics famously go
“Sippin’ on gin and juice, laid back,
with my mind on my money
and my money on my mind."
In the song, Snoop references
a brand of gin called Seagram's,
and the success of the song
"Gin and Juice"
led to a roughly 20 percent increase
in Seagram's gin sales.
Now you may be thinking,
"Alright, Samir, I see the point
you're trying to make,
but using hip hop to sell alcohol is easy.
Climate change is a little bit
more complex."
Fair enough.
But there are examples
of how hip hop artists have leveraged
their cultural capital
to influence society's views on
and engagement with
incredibly serious topics.
Take mental health, for example.
In the 1970s,
one of the early hip-hop groups
called Grandmaster Flash
and the Furious Five
rapped about the day-to-day inequities
and injustices faced by Black communities
in the United States
and how this impacted their mental health.
One of their songs called "The Message"
was the seventh rap song to ever be
on any Billboard Hot 100 chart,
and New York Times named it
as the most popular pop single of 1982.
Sorry, the most powerful
pop single of 1982.
And then in the '80s and '90s,
mental health issues started to become
more mainstream in hip hop lyrics.
In 1991,
in their classic song
"Mind Playing Tricks on Me,"
hip hop group Geto Boys
captured the realities
of post-traumatic stress
within urban communities.
One of the three members of the group
named Scarface wrote most of the song.
You see, he was diagnosed
with bipolar disorder at a young age,
and the lyrics of the song describe
the mental anguish and exhaustion
for life of minorities in America
dealing with symptoms
of post-traumatic stress disorder,
loneliness, suicidal
ideation and paranoia.
And then in 2017,
hip hop artist Logic
released his song "1-800-273-8255"
That's the phone number for the National
Suicide Prevention Lifeline.
The week before the song was released,
Logic tweeted,
"I made this song for all of you
who are in a dark place
and can't seem to find the light."
The director of the National
Suicide Prevention Lifeline said
that on the day the song was released,
they had the second-highest call volume
in the history of their service.
And after Logic performed the song
on MTV's Video Music Awards
later that year,
they reported a 50 percent
increase in call volume.
You can see that while talking
about the problem
to raise awareness is important,
it's not until Logic started
rapping about a solution
that things really started changing.
And that,
that's the power of hip hop.
Hip hop has always taken complex topics
and made them mainstream and cool.
Hip hop has always influenced
the behavior of its listeners.
Hip hop has always given voice
to the underrepresented.
What if hip hop took a complex topic
like climate change
and made it mainstream and cool?
Or if hip hop influenced
behavior that protected our planet?
Or if hip hop gave voice
to the environment or future generations
who can't speak for themselves.
Now using popular music
to raise awareness about climate change
has already started happening.
Two years ago,
the New York Times reported
that there have been at least
192 references to climate change
in any song that has been
made by any artist
who has been featured on any
of Billboard's domestic charts
over the past two decades.
So not a lot.
And I only knew a handful of the songs.
We need a lot more of that.
But more importantly,
we need lyrics of songs to transition
from talking about the problem
into the solution space.
I mean, if you're a rapper, a songwriter,
a producer, a musician, we need you.
We listen to you.
I bet most, if not all of you here
have made a decision because of music.
I certainly have.
I mean, when I was younger,
the first Air Force 1s I bought,
these are not Air Force 1s,
but the first Air Force 1s I bought
were because of Nelly's song.
Now, imagine if instead of rapping
or singing about Maybachs or Cadillacs,
the most influential
hip hop artists in the world
made electric vehicles aspirational.
Or instead of rapping about the bling
around their necks or in their mouths,
they rapped about the solar panel
bling on their roofs.
Don't get me wrong,
the songs that I'm referencing
helped define my childhood.
But what if my childhood was defined
by environmentalism?
What if next year the Grammy Award
for Best Album or Best Song
or Best Rap Album went to an artist
who used their platform
to make one of the most important topics
of our generation mainstream?
To bring climate to the culture.
What if that got climate solutions
to be part of our vernacular?
Would that create a movement
or raise the masses
or get people behind an idea
to inspire action?
I think so.
Imagine the influence we can have.
See, we have this incredible opportunity
to participate in the biggest
revolution we have ever seen.
The revolution to secure a livable future.
And I believe that hip hop and culture
are part of the solution.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)